[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on peut apprécier l'économie on peut
aimer l'économie il ne suffit pas
d'aimer pour bien la décrypter
la France est entrée dans la spirale
infernale des 3D les excès de la dépense
publique en générant des déficits
conduisent au recours coupables à la
dette mais de quoi parle-t-on on parle
de cet enchaînement de la dépense
alimentant des déficits dont la dette
est un des recours possibles le budget
de l'État comme n'importe quel budget
peut avoir un solde déficitaire ou
excellentaire le déficit public est donc
lorsque le solde est déficitaire on a eu
des périodes un peu plus florissantes en
France du début de la 5ème jusqu'en 1966
il y avait des excédents interrompus par
les accords de Grenelle en 68 et puis la
période de 69 à 1974 donnera des
déficits à 0 en moyenne donc situation
plutôt stable côté recettes il s'agit
essentiellement de prélèvement
obligatoire on pourrait dire les impôts
mais c'est un peu plus complexe il y a
des impôts et des cotisations sociales
et dans les impôts en France on a cette
particularité de cotisation sociale
fiscalisées il s'agit de la CRDS et de
la CSG principalement les impôts
alimentent la ce qui est constitué en
gros là encore bien de consommation
intermédiaire ça parlera au comptable de
la rémunération des agents de
prestations sociales mais aussi de
toutes ces subventions et autres
transferts qui sont importants et
conséquents et puis charge d'intérêt de
la dette et l'investissement formation
brute de capital fixe si on regarde un
petit peu dans dans le détail des choses
mais très succinctement et de façon très
simple on voit aussi que finalement la
dépense n'est pas au seul usage exclusif
d'un état égoïste puisque calculer en
2016 la répartition par nature des
dépenses publiques laisse apercevoir que
pratiquement 60% plus précisément
58,10% de cette dépense est constituée à
des usages de transfert de
redistribution et cette distribution
elle n'est pas l'apanage d'une seule
strate de l'État ce ne sont pas que les
administrations de sécurité sociale qui
redistribue mais toutes les strates de
l'État quelle strates et bien lorsqu'on
parle de l'État au sens large du terme
il faut savoir qu'il se décompose entre
alors si on prend les acronymes on va
parler de apuc à pull et à sous applique
pour administration publique centrale
c'est l'État central et sur le plan du
budget la dépense de l'État central elle
est un peu moins de 40 % de l'ensemble
de la structure s'agissant des du volley
social les assos le volet social est
plus important puisqu'il dépasse en gros
et en moyenne 40 % de la structure et
pour arriver à 100% il reste le la
dépense des administrations locales qui
est à un peu moins de 20% dépense
recette lorsque la dépense excède la
recette il y a forcément un déficit le
déficit va montrer cette excellent et va
obliger à trouver une solution le
déficit oblige soit à augmenter les
impôts donc le volet recettes assez
automatiquement on pourrait le croire
mais c'était pas toujours aussi simple
ou alors le cas échéant lorsqu'on ne
peut pas augmenter les impôts on a
recours à la dette qui est un recours
qui peut sembler lui aussi assez facile
mais il va impacter les génération votre
futur parce que la dette d'aujourd'hui
ce sera les impôts des générations
futures si rien d'autre n'est fait si la
croissance ne revient pas et cet
arbitrage c'est à l'état de faire
l'arbitrage pour colmater le déficit il
va choisir entre impôts et emprunt mais
il ne le fera pas de façon je dirais
indépendante il peut le faire en
fonction de son idéologie en fonction de
ses contraintes il n'est pas toujours
facile d'augmenter les impôts surtout
lorsqu'il y a crise on va donc se
retourner vers la dette la dette
publique pour avoir une idée pour
définir un peu la dette publique ce
n'est pas simple l'un non plus parce
qu'il y a trois quatre cinq définitions
possibles de la dette publique je vous
en donnerai simplement deux celles qu'on
utilise le plus souvent c'est la dette
publique alors brute au sens de
Maastricht et puis on pourrait mettre en
face la dette publique nette au sens de
l'Insee par exemple et si on prend les
chiffres plus précis afin 2021 et bien
on pourra dire au sens de masse riche
que la dette publique était de alors
dernière correction parce que là encore
c'est à la marge mais de 2813 milliards
soit 112,5% du PIB alors qu'au sens de
l'Insee la dette publique nette était de
2522 milliards soit 101,2% du PIB on
peut
débattre des chiffres simplement là
encore ça démontre aussi que en la
matière la précision est toujours
compliquée à voir puisqu'il y a révision
correction la façon dont on va exprimer
les choses peut avoir aussi son
importance juste deux ordres de grandeur
sur ces définitions statistiques la
dépense publique s'exprime en
pourcentage du PIB pour une question
d'homogénéité pour pouvoir faire des
comparaisons et dans le temps et dans
l'espace avec nos voisins on la calcule
en fonction de la richesse que le pays
est capable de créer en France en 2022
la dépense publique exprimée en
pourcentage du PIB et de 57,5% du PIB on
prévoit à la fin du mandat dans le
programme de stabilisation de la faire
redescendre à 53,5% du PIB le déficit
est aujourd'hui à -4,7% du PIB
encore ambitionne de le réduire à moins
2,7% du PIB juste en dessous de ce que
Maastricht imposait dans la définition
des critères qui étaient de 3%. et puis
reste la dette plus gros problème pour
la France elle est aujourd'hui encore à
111,6% du PIB et les optimistes vous
disent qu'elle pourra revenir à 108,3 %
du PIB telle est en tout cas les
prévisions que l'on a presque Bercy a
proposé à Bruxelles donc cette dette
représente en gros on frôle les 3000
milliards d'euros ça représente 43000
euros par français 43000 euros par
française c'est deux ans et demi de Smic
net ou c'est encore l'équivalent de 10
millions de Tesla pour la gamme la plus
chère pour faire un panorama rapide de
l'évolution de toutes ces grandeurs de
la dépense des déficits et de la dette
sur la 5ème et en se concentrant
précisément comme l'indique les
graphiques sur la période de 74 à nos
jours on peut commencer par une remarque
évoquer des excédents budgétaires ça ne
parle pas pas toutes les générations qui
sont nées après 1975 si on considère que
ça n'est pas leur quotidien force et de
constater que depuis bientôt 50 ans le
pays vit au-dessus de ses moyens et à
des déficits de plus en plus importants
on a des effets de palier qui sont se
réaliser depuis bientôt 50 ans le pays
vit au-dessus de ses moyens pour la
bonne cause certainement c'est la tâche
de l'État mais n'est peut-être pas
injuste de réclamer à l'état la même
rigueur que celle que notre banquier
nous demande de là plusieurs
interrogations aurait-il pu agir
autrement oui et non oui car les
déficits sont en grande partie alimentés
par un excès de dépenses sur les
recettes oui parce que c'est de la
responsabilité politique et économique
de l'État d'un gouvernement de mettre en
place des mesures dans le cadre d'une
politique économique sur laquelle il a
été élu oui il aurait pu agir autrement
en se souant d'abord des recettes avant
les dépenses en faisant ce que les
Anglais appellent taxe and spend taxé et
dépenser ensuite plutôt que d'avoir ce
comportement qu'on peut dire laxisme qui
consiste à d'abord dépenser et puis se
préoccuper ensuite du financement par
l'impôt ou par la dette un impôt qui
alimente la dépense ça signifie aussi
qu'on va choisir les victimes celles qui
vont financer qui vont avoir un
supplément d'impôt au bénéfice de ce qui
profiteront de la dépense supplémentaire
je dis profiter dans un sens objectif
non pas péjoratif se pose alors la
question du consentement l'impôt la
question de la possibilité de l'impôt
parce qu'il y a un paradoxe en période
de crise les besoins sont d'autant plus
importants que la crise est profonde et
solliciter une population par des impôts
supplémentaires est contre-productif
puisque l'assiette de l'impôt se
réduisant il est compliqué de faire
peser encore plus lourdement l'impôt sur
cette assiette il reste donc la solution
de la dette mais là encore il faut bien
regarder la charge de la dette le coût
de la dette et aujourd'hui le
retournement à la hausse des taux
d'intérêt marque une rupture puisqu'il
va coûter de plus en plus cher à l'état
de son comme aux particuliers d'ailleurs
donc on aurait pu aussi considérer que
ce n'était pas la seule solution pour
l'État on aurait pu répondre non en
disant nos voisins font différemment
chaque fois qu'on se compare à
l'Allemagne on observe et en 2022 quand
la France annonce 57,5 % de dépenses
publiques l'Allemagne est en dessous de
50 % à 49,7 précisément le déficit
allemand est à -2,6 c'est un projet que
l'on a pour 2027 en France la France
prévoit de s'approcher de ce résultat
sans parler de la dette qui en Allemagne
est revenue à un peu plus de 60% alors
qu'on est à pratiquement le double en
France si on prend les
précisions l'expression en termes de
pourcentage du PIB alors l'axisme
l'absence volontarisme politique ça va
finir par se voir disait Pierre
Moscovici il y a déjà un an alors est-ce
que on l'a entendu il y a un retour à la
raison dans le programme de
stabilisation dans les prévisions que
Bercy vient d'envoyer à Bruxelles il y a
la volonté d'un refroidissement pour ne
pas dire une purge est-ce que les
doivent s'attendre à une politique de
rigueur la question est posée et
d'autres encore reprochent à la France
sur laxisme la France
est montée du doigt l'Allemagne réclame
des engagements chiffrés de la part des
États et un désengagement chiffré de la
part des États on peut se poser la
question du réalisme pourquoi pas sur la
France a toujours abusé de la situation
où l'on peut dire qu'elle est trop
importante pour qu'on la laisse tomber
to big to Feld disent des Américains si
elles tombent elle entraîne le reste de
la cordée et on comprend bien que ça
peut poser problème et l'Europe a la
volonté d'avoir une convergence de ces
économies autre difficulté au-delà de la
crédibilité des sanctions ou de la
volonté de protéger une souveraineté
budgétaire le pays veut être responsable
de son budget et bien il reste encore
des déclarations qui peuvent être des
bonnes intentions et ces bonnes
intentions s'inscrivent dans un
environnement qui lui-même est
imprévisible l'État s'engage à faire le
résultat ne sera peut-être pas celui
attendu parce qu'il a peut-être voulu en
faire trop
il a un peu dissimulé ses intentions
mais aussi peut-être parce que
l'environnement va évoluer de façon
pénalisante et empêchera d'atteindre ses
objectifs ça signifie quoi ça signifie
que le risque zéro n'existe pas qui
aurait pu prévoir le covid certainement
personne la même chose si on reprend un
peu historiquement les choses les deux
chocs pétrolier ont été les premiers
éléments les premières crises qui vont
impacter
le comportement de détails qui vont
l'obliger à dépenser au-delà de ce qu'il
avait prévu de faire les dépenses
publiques vont dépasser les 45% et à
l'arrivée de la gauche au pouvoir on
aura un pic à 52% en 1984 et puis un peu
plus loin à nouveau des crises une
récession en 1993 mais là cette fois la
récession est mondiale ajoutée à la
guerre du Golfe nous fera franchir un
palier à plus de 55%. et plus loin en
2007 Nicolas Sarkozy qui est arrivé au
pouvoir avec de bonnes intentions de
travailler plus pour gagner plus et
d'avoir cette volonté de récompenser les
efforts ne pourra pas faire autrement
que quelques victimes de deux crises
d'ampleur importantes faire
véritablement exploser la dépense
publique à 57% du PIB à rebours du
programme qu'il avait prévu Emmanuel
Macron ne sera pas donc épargné on l'a
vu crise sanitaire ajoutée à des
contraintes géopolitiques il sera incité
un peu à je vais dire des choses entre
guillemets agir sans réfléchir sans
réfléchir à ce qu'il en coûte à ce qu'il
en coûtera de sorte que les dépenses
publiques vont dépasser cette fois les
61% du PIB en 2019 revenus à
57,5% du PIB en 2022 ça reste ce niveau
dépenses publiques un record sur toute
la cinquième hors période de covid n’y
aurait-il donc que des cercles vicieux
non on le sait de 86 à 88 la France a
expérimenté la seule politique de
l'offre politique de l'offre pourquoi
parce qu'elle a réussi à baisser et les
impôts et la dépense et cette situation
n'a pas été très importante sur l'impact
en termes de réduction de la dépense
mais ça quand même des dépenses
publiques qui sont revenues partant de
52,3 en 85 à 50,6%, 1988 ça permettra au
gouvernement Rocard de démarrer en 89
avec une dépense publique sous les 50% à
49,5 très précisément pour un temps
court seulement un peu plus loin de 98 à
2000 c'est grâce en partie pour prendre
là encore les situations bénéfiques
c'est grâce en partie à une croissance
vigoureuse qui est aussi drame entre 3,4
et 3,9% que Lionel Jospin sera en partie
capable de diminuer la dépense publique
pour la ramener à 51,7% du PIB en 2000
et en 2001 en gros quand on regarde les
chiffres au plus près le constat
empirique que l'on a pu faire c'est que
à partir de 1994 et surtout la période à
l'exception de trois dates à l'exception
de 98 99 et 2000 depuis 94 chaque fois
que la dépense publique dépasse les
49,5% du PIB la croissance
bien aidé par la bonne conjoncture
parvient à retenir un peu la dette la
ramener à 58,3% du PIB en 2001 ensuite
elle repartira à la hausse 110 continuer
atteignant près de 65% en 2006 et puis
les deux crises sous Nicolas Sarkozy lui
feront tutoyer des sommets
87%, elle s'arrêtera de justesse avant
les 100% sous François Hollande à 98%
plus précisément elle retombera pour une
courte période en 2019 calme avant la
tempête pourrait-on dire à
97,4%, les conséquences du covid vont
engager un rythme effréné de la dette
publique et ses conséquences se liront
dans un taux qui atteindra 114 % du PIB
et désormais à 111,6% prévu à 108,3 pour
la fin du mandat certains se demandent
si l'on n'est pas si l'on ne serait pas
passé d'un laxisme le disputant au déni
à un excès d'optimisme comme une sorte
de défi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]